le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
loyer factures frais de scolarité il est
parfois difficile d'assurer toutes ces
dépenses
lorsque l'on est étudiant pour aider les
jeunes dans leur parcours scolaire et
professionnel
le département propose plusieurs types
d' aide via son dispositif net bourse
kelly jean-michel shaqif à ou encore
rachel sont des étudiants aux parcours
différents à la réunion ou en métropole
en école privée ou à l'université
ils ont tous les trois bénéficier du
dispositif net bourse
m
c'est dans les hauts de sainte marie que
kelly expérimente pour la première fois
le confort d'un chez soi
étudiante en espagnol à saint denis elle
a passé cinq ans à faire des allers
retours depuis le sud de l'île avant
j'étais à l'etang-salé tous les jours
faute de moyens kelly ne pouvait pas
assumer un loyer sur saint denis
elle est donc restée chez ses parents le
temps de ses études en terme de
budget c'était assez réduite évident
forcément de ma d'assurer tous ses frais
annexes à la scolarité comme kelly ils
sont nombreux chaque année à chercher le
juste équilibre entre études et budget
pour les aider le département a mis en
place une bourse accessible au plus
grand nombre
pour compléter l'aide nationale
existante qu'on a droit donc l'impôt sur
crous contre un boxeur nationale et
l'applaudimètre
donc est ce une bourse départementale on
a des personnes dans l'année donc un
selon différentes ses cheveux longs qui
dépendent du rheu son prince une
dépendance à comprend un logement pour
pouvoir séculier
ça demande énormément de frais de
logement
les courses
tout ce qui suit je croule amoureux du
crous à ça reste quand même de monter
dans la mort du net elle qui vit près
par sa soutenance de fin d'études
elle espère devenir enseignante dans le
secondaire comme elle
jean michel a choisi de poursuivre ses
études sur saint denis
il étudie l'informatique en troisième
année à l'école supinfo l'impression que
j'étais prédestiné en fait j'étais
curieux de de l'informatique en général
je voulais faire moi en fait comment
pouvait fonctionner annonce est un
concours en fabriquer comme ensuite aux
poupées et des choses jean michel habite
chez ses parents
ce qui lui fait économiser un loyer mais
il a choisi des études poussées les
frais de scolarité de son école dépasse
les 1000 euros ce qui permet à
l'étudiant de bénéficier d'une aide
supplémentaire
l'allocation de scolarité vue de 20 la
beauce
bourreau peine et j'ai aussi le
remboursement des frais scolaires
ça m'a beaucoup aidé puisqu'on école
c'est 5000 euros comme un parent ce qui
fait que
pour moi c'est un peu difficile de payer
avec l'ont fait chaque année avec le
départ beaucoup
s'il valide sa licence cette année
jean-michel pense partir vers la
métropole pour la suite de ses études
la mobilité c'est aussi le choix de
chaque ifa après l'obtention d'un bts
communication sur l'île elle s'envole
vers la métropole
dans ma branche shaqif à étudie le
marketing à lyon pendant deux ans et
effectue sa dernière année de master à
londres comme pour ses compatriotes
restés sur l'île le logement reste la
principale difficulté de l'étudiante et
en angleterre
pareil les loyers absolument être en
colocation sinon on ne peut pas s'en
sortir et les transports
pour les étudiants qui doivent se loger
sur paris le département dispose
également de 85 chambres réservées aux
réunionnais au centre internationale
universitaire de paris
rachel étudie l'événementiel son dossier
a été sélectionnés sur des critères de
ressources familiales
déjà c'est très compliqué d'avoir un
logement sur paris il pouvoir venir ici
tous les services où c'est sécurisé où
tu peux te faire du plein d'amis des
amis aussi réunionnais et étrangers faut
vraiment le prends comme une chance
une expérience à vivre et donc vraiment
profité pour l'année scolaire 2015 2016
le département a attribué plus de dix
mille bourses une aide financière mais
surtout un levier pour réussir dans les
meilleures conditions son parcours
scolaire et professionnel
il est très important de porter nos
jeunes dans leur parcours d'excellence
et contribuer à la dynamique de la
société réunionnaise est un atout
formidable pour notre pays demain et
bien sûr l'essentiel dans l'est de
catherine ii
le département vers nos jeunes
réunionnais c'est vraiment les pousser
vraiment à voir demain un parcours
professionnel et avoir un bon projet
pour qu'ils réussissent leur avenir
le dispositif qu'on est bourse a pour
objectif d'accompagner les étudiants
tout au long de leur parcours
il concerne les formations de niveau bac
+ 1 à bac +5 en formation initiale et à
plein temps le dispositif propose deux
aides
la bourse départementale s'adresse à
tous les étudiants
elle peut aller de 375 à 2150 euros
selon le lieu d'étude et les ressources
familiales l'allocation de scolarité
concerne les formations dites
d'excellence dont les frais de scolarité
sont supérieurs à 1000 euros
elle peut aller de 2000 à 6000 euros
selon les conditions de ressources
pour plus d'information ou pour
s'inscrire une seule plateforme met
tirer bourse pour un cg974 point fr vous
pouvez aussi appeler le numéro vert 0
800 800 596
non